I thought about that a lot particularly
when I had the honor to be elected
president of Ireland first of all I put
a light in the window of the official
residence for all of those who'd had to
emigrate because when I was growing up
in Mayo emigration was just a terrible
terrible loss there was a book written
about no one shall stop and I wanted to
gather in that wider Irish family and
there were a number of reasons for that
we were trying to build the
reconciliation and peace process in
Northern Ireland and I felt that the
Irish are in fact much more diverse than
we think we're all over the world and we
have intermingled intermarried and we've
made our contribution so by gathering in
that Irish diaspora I think it was very
helpful to a modern sense of a more open
Irishness which went beyond being
Catholic and Republican to embracing the
many strands of Irishness
you